I appreciate it
two weeks ago we brought you the story
of Richard Romano a double amputee
veteran on the brink of homelessness
after he says his caregiver stole
thousands from him but now he's housed
has food with a brighter future ahead
for now Ryan Matthey caught up with him
today and the friend who has tirelessly
worked to keep him off the streets it's
cold out here huh two Richards are
better than one especially when one
can't make it alone now I got a place to
sleep place to stay for a while we first
met 81 year old Richard Romano back in
November a double amputee veteran who
was evicted from his Las Vegas apartment
when he could not pay rent the reason
his caregiver who allegedly stole nearly
five thousand dollars from him when I
called they said they couldn't they
couldn't reimburse me because I gave my
PIN number to him I was exhausted my
resource is I don't have the money to do
it with no family to turn to his close
friend Richard Stevens has worked to
keep him off the street after our first
interview a family responded to this
next doorpost saying they could take him
in with a new licensed caregiver hey
potentially got kicked out of their home
sheltered in secret thankfully Veteran
Affairs confirmed with eight news now
they are working to get him permanent
shelter Adult Protective Services they
say are helping too the agencies that
Romano says has helped rethink his
decision to not prosecute his old
caregiver everybody I talked to said
that I should prosecute him I shouldn't
let him get away with it because he'll
do it to somebody else
you know so that made me think about
while things may look good now it's
temporary Prosecuting could take years
most of the money he lost may never be
recovered and he's got to be out of his
current living situation by the end of
this month but with the community's help
they have hope that means the world to
me man means the world that everybody
was somebody wants to help me
it's so hard for me
we'll make sure to keep you updated on
his situation now in the meantime the
friend is now accepting donations to
cover a certain costs of housing the
veteran now you can uh if you have if
you want more information on how to help
just head over to our website
8newsnow.com